we don't know whether there is life of
any kind beyond Earth but I think that
the 21st century is the century in which
we're going to answer that question my
name is Jill tarter I'm the director
emeritus of SETI research at the SETI
Institute we're here to talk about the
search for extraterrestrial intelligence
or actually the search for
extraterrestrial technology we've been
at this SETI business since 1960 and you
might think that we must have searched
everything but in fact we've searched
almost nothing a total volume that we
need to explore set that equal to the
volume of all the Earth's oceans
well since 1960 we've actually searched
maybe a hot tubs worth of the ocean
really not very much it's such a huge
universe out there and we've observed
such a small part of it
do I believe in aliens it's not the
right question we're talking about a
scientific exploration whatever anyone
believes has no relevance you want to
know what is odds are reasonable that
the chemistry and physics that provided
biology on this planet may have done so
elsewhere
we have always asked are we alone we've
wanted to know who's over the next hill
what's out there I think we should try
and answer it if they help us answer it
because they come here okay
just this morning jet fighters raced
aloft over ripe Patterson Air Force Base
at Dayton Ohio to intercept a reported
saucer returning pilots swore that it
was a life that could not have been a
reflection and that it evaded them at a
very high rate of speed unidentified
flying objects there there I've seen one
they're not necessarily related to alien
spacecraft there's just no evidence that
holds up that says that things that are
seen on camera for example on the Navy
radars have anything to do with
extraterrestrials baseball I can't
explain claims of
alien spacecraft seen by radar I can say
that that's new technology it isn't
necessarily very stable yet the most
often reported UFO is the planet Venus
people when they look at a dark sky
don't really understand what they're
seeing
they're conflating perhaps their desires
to see an extraterrestrial spacecraft
with whatever is actually happening
there until about 25 years ago
high-altitude military airplanes saw
this bright lights above thunder clouds
that were totally unexplained we didn't
understand until we got satellites with
high time resolution cameras looking
down at their that lightning travels up
as well as down and now we have a whole
new physics of sprites and elves above
thunder clouds so that was a bit of new
physics that was observed not understood
sometimes conflated with alien
spacecraft and I'm sure that a lot of
that is happening today
whether or not an extraterrestrial
visitor is benevolent or potentially a
threat is something of which various
people have various opinions Stephen
Hawking is known for saying you know
when Columbus showed up in the new world
it didn't work out really well for the
natives but I think that's that's the
wrong analogy the ability to travel
interstellar distances and actually show
up at our doorstep
is amazing a huge technological gap that
we can't reach at this point so I think
anything that they could need or want
they
can manufacture in their own home system
also to have become that advanced
technologically I think they have to be
a lot older than we are
and I think they've had to outgrow the
violent and competitive characteristic
that probably was part of their infancy
I don't have any reason to worry about
an older technology that manages to come
here I think what they're interested in
is curiosity is about us we don't know
what they might look like they're gonna
look like the planet they evolved on we
have evolved on a planet that is
illuminated by a Sun so we have eyes
that perceive light had we evolved on a
planet that's circled a small red dwarf
star we might have different sensors our
eyes might not see visible they might
sense heat and infrared had we evolved
on a planet that had more gravity
because it was bigger than the earth we
might be flatter had we evolved on a
planet that was mostly ocean we might
have gills it doesn't matter to me
what they look like and I think nature
is probably a lot more imaginative than
I am
the difference between life and
intelligence actually is getting more
difficult to discern we used to have
this very very privileged opinion that
we were intelligent and the rest of the
planet was just alive we're beginning to
understand the the breadth of
intelligence across a huge line of
species extremophiles are forms of life
that live in conditions that we humans
for example couldn't tolerate at the
bottom of the ocean where the magma is
boiling up they live actually in
channels within ice frozen and ice it is
the ability of life to live in
environments which would be lethal
instantly to humans that encourages us
to think that there's more habitable
real estate out there than we might have
thought when we started the SETI quest
we didn't know whether there were
planets around other stars now we know
thanks to ground-based telescopes and
the Kepler spacecraft that there are
more planets than stars in the Milky Way
galaxy every star has at least one
planet statistically that was something
we didn't know until just a couple of
years ago the discovery of exoplanets
everywhere the discovery of
extremophiles on earth it has made this
whole search for intelligent
technological life elsewhere seem much
more reasonable and realistic
what we say we're doing is looking for
extraterrestrial intelligence but in
fact we've decided to use technology as
a proxy for intelligence we look for
some kinds of signals that are generated
that nature can't manufacture we look
for large astroengineering kinds of
structures and we assume if we found the
technology that there is some
intelligent technologists
who created it techno signatures can be
something that it leaks or is the result
of engineering done for their only
purposes or techno signatures can be
deliberate attempts to make something
that's detectable over interstellar
distances astrobiologists tend to be
interested in finding bio signatures
things that they can look for within our
solar system on Mars on the moons of
Jupiter and Saturn that would indicate
biology bio signatures we talk about the
Moon or Mars or other planets in our
solar system or beyond the solar system
no to date we have no evidence of life
if we find life we need to ask question
about whether that life is related to us
whether an early rock from Earth got
chipped off and seeded Mars or
vice-versa early in the solar system the
formation of the solar system it was
very violent and rocks were exchanged
between Venus Earth Mars and the idea
that one of those rocks might have
contained some kind of life that
in a condition a spore that could
survive the transference from one body
to another within the solar system
that's panspermia in physics we count
one to infinity if we have one example
it could be singular the moment you find
a second example then you know it's
universal so if we find a second genesis
of life in our solar system
independently involved a new evolution
of life we will know that life is
everywhere out there we're listening
we're trying to say is there anyone out
there whose technology we can detect
SETI started observational e in 1960 to
listen for radio signals that were
confined to a single channel on the
radio dial we have evolved from there
much broader receivers bigger radio
dials many many more channels and we're
listening for different kinds of
patterns in frequency and time in the
future we'll bring in artificial
intelligence and neural networks to look
for different kinds of patterns that
aren't natural
we are listening we are actually not
transmitting deliberately at the moment
so there's a controversy in the SETI
community about whether we should just
listen or whether in fact it's necessary
for us to deliberately transmit I have a
problem with the transmitting bit we
sometimes manage two year plans or five
year plans but we just can't manage
10,000 year plans and I think if you're
going to transmit you have to do so with
a determination that you're going to do
it for a long time it's something you've
got to commit to and I don't think we're
grown-up enough yet as I said
to do that but when and if we do become
a long-lived stable technological
civilization then I think transmission
continuous transmission in all
directions or to a very large number of
targets that are potentially habitable
hosts for other civilizations that
becomes a plan that we take on in the
future when we can commit to long term
planning we're too young now we should
listen first see what's out there you've
got lots and lots of problems on this
planet why should we be spending any
money at all on trying to find out
whether there are other creatures out
there and the answer is because looking
for life and intelligent life beyond
this planet has the effect of holding up
a mirror and that mirror shows all of us
on this planet shows us all as the same
when compared to something else out
there we are all the same and I think
that this is incredibly important for
our long-term future because the
challenges on this planet that we face
do not recognize national boundaries
they are challenges that are going to
have to be worked on globally in a
cooperative fashion and so the more that
we see ourselves not as individuals not
as Americans not as Europeans and honest
Chinese the more that we see ourselves
as Earthlings as humans the more likely
we are to be able to find a way to
manage these global challenges so I
think SETI even if we never detect
evidence of someone else I think
thinking about it talking to people
about it getting the world to encompass
that sort of cosmic perspective
is something that will help us manage to
get to a long future
[Music]